always have to be prepared to walk I
could have signed an agreement today and
then you people would have said oh what
a terrible deal what a terrible thing he
did now you'll have to be prepared to
walk and you know there was a potential
we could have signed something today I
could have a hundred percent sign
something today we actually had papers
ready to be signed but it just wasn't
appropriate I want to do it right I'd
much rather do it right than do it fast
they wanted to de nuke certain areas and
I wanted everything and the sanctions
are there and I didn't want to give up
the sanctions unless we had a real
program and they're not ready for that
and I understand that fully I really do
I mean they spent a lot of time building
it and that doesn't mean the world has
to be happy but I wanted them to alright
so how do you know when the media routes
for failure when they spend days saying
Trump will give away the farm then mock
him when he doesn't the surprise ending
to this very trumpian cliffhanger is
nothing this is second time the United
States has lost in Vietnam strike one in
Singapore he didn't get a deal with Kim
jong-un now it's strike two in Hanoi
once again no deal to denuclearize North
Korea something that he's staked a lot
of his legacy a lot of his presidency on
so Trump left without a deal now if you
believe that this is a a sign of failure
B represents the whole process then C
you flunk this quiz fact is walking away
as part of the process which is slow and
odd sometimes it's better to appear
going backwards or making nice even when
it looks really bad but the lines of
communication exist even when they're
crossed so by walking away a part of
negotiating we actually move ahead Trump
went there told the guy hey the
sanctions stay that's a first and that's
progress and it could be that North
Korea is unsolvable but if there's a
solution it involves talking and I don't
know about you but I feel safer than I
did a year ago because of talking
remember Hawaii but if you still believe
that we can see
a lot with just a meeting then you're a
relic preferring to settle things
through the currency of corpses meaning
war old people throwing bodies at each
other for you blood is an endless
commodity but for the more peaceful
types we'll see what happens was a
daring alternative to the status quo
which is having bureaucrats and Hawaiian
shirts telling you telling your family
to seek shelter so this is gonna take a
while its long-term effort with
short-term pain the long-term benefit
will bring peace short-term pain the
media who screws the world over by
making any deal look like a concession
in short Trump has a long game which is
better than the media which has no game
at all
Jessie the media is gloating even though
they make the world less safe yeah you
shouldn't be celebrating the fact that
North Korea still has missiles pointed
at us it's a very hard problem if it was
easy the last three presidents would
have solved it yes I don't like the way
they set him up they say was going to go
over there and sign a bad deal to
distract from Cohen so he goes over
there doesn't sign a bad deal and now
they say he can't deal yeah I think what
happened was track from Cohen yes yes he
did
and we'll have Cohen next block it could
be in the a block at any time honestly I
think what happened nice tease I think
what happened was is the Chinese
probably told Kim to scuttle this thing
use this as leverage for the trade deal
because remember Trump said he was going
to drop the tariff increase on March
first so it's a big kind of gamesmanship
between Chee and Trump and like he says
we'll see what happens I don't like the
deal at all if they wanted to destroy
their main nuclear plant in exchange for
dropping all sanctions that's crazy it's
it's you know an obvious phrase but no
deal is better than a bad deal it's very
easy to do a deal and I think the media
likes the idea of a deal and they don't
care what's in it it was easy to make
the Iran deal just give them a bunch of
cash and let them keep all their
missiles I mean it's easy to do deals
it's very difficult to do tough deals
and this is a long-term problem
dan I just I this is what you call a
lose-lose proposition with the media if
he made a deal they would say it's a
concession so he doesn't get a deal now
he's just incompetent right and that's
why I think that leaders
to ignore it yeah you just do the right
thing and you move on you explain it the
best that you can I didn't like the
comment from the MSNBC commentator in
your montage mm-hmm this is the second
time they dose in Vietnam and that is
obviously so ridiculous in melodramatic
and we are clearly in a better place and
we're than we were at the end of 2017
yeah right so there's that and sue me
Terry she's a expert on Korea Korean
issues she said North Korea is the land
of no good options yeah okay but what I
do think they're in a better place but
so is Kim yeah now he isn't an elevated
position he's like oh yeah look at me
and he's got a little bit of swagger but
he also has our attention so I don't
think that the sanctions are gonna get
any easier for him I don't think that
his buddies the Chinese or the Russians
are going to necessarily be of help to
him and he has just raised the bar so
high for a third summit that he's going
to have to give something because
apparently there is reporting that on
the Secretary of State was warning the
president this guy is not coming with
good intentions he doesn't have any plan
to do it but we went ahead with the
summit anyway but now we know where
everybody stands yeah
Kennedy he didn't look that well when he
was there Kim you know he he looked
tired slow and corpulent yes sweaty
there are three adjectives I don't want
associated with me when I'm a big peace
treaty but I will say this I think the
president's right when he says that
North Korea can become an economic
powerhouse that's absolutely true and I
think there are there are a lot of a lot
of countries in the world who would like
to do trade with North Korea that is
denuclearized where the labor camps have
been open and that you know those poor
prisoners those who have survived are
freed as are their families and that
would be a great story and I think there
are a lot of people who would be
snapping up bargains but I don't think
kim jeong-hoon would be the leader in
such a climate I really and he knows
this that if he gives up his nukes
he gives up his power and he really has
nothing else to offer his country
because once they realize that that free
market barn-door can swing open those
horses are going to leave in search of
economic mobility and opportunity and
by definition he doesn't not only he
doesn't want to offer that to his people
because he wants to remain in control he
doesn't know how mm-hmm
one one of the consequences of playing
nice is that you play to nice and I
think President Trump got a lot of guff
from the media over his statements over
otto warmbier about saying that he he
took Kim president Kim jong-un at his
word and that was that did not play well
here what are your thoughts well I think
it particularly didn't play well with
Republicans because I mean even on this
show in this network we have talked
about otto warmbier as a victim of a
tyrant and what we've seen from his
parents is absolute torture with what
they were going through for their kid
and then you have President Trump today
saying he takes Kim jong-un's word well
I mean a lot of people I mean you know
Rob Portman from Ohio but also you know
a number of the Republican leading
Republican senators said that's
unacceptable that why would you do that
so to me this plays into I think you
know President Trump thinks that the key
to negotiation is flatter right that I
can build a personal relationship I'll
make you feel loved and secure and then
we'll make a deal well it clearly didn't
happen and I think that for lots of
people in the foreign policy
establishment they think well why don't
you do it in a more substantive way in
which you think about and plan what it
is you're willing to do and what you
think the other guy will do instead
Trump says I don't believe our
intelligence agencies I don't believe
dan coates I don't believe Deena Haspel
they're wrong I believe Kim jong-un's
well that's it's it's not it that
destabilizes us and then we give him a
platform Dana was picking up on this
we've elevated Kim jong-un in this
process Jesse says hey well maybe it's
about China and the terrorists deal in
China is putting pressure on them but
again who put themselves in that
position it was us because rather than
go about serial step by step negotiation
we just took a flyer here and it really
didn't work out all right we got a toss
to guess what we have Michael Cohen he's
speaking there he is
other than it was very productive as I
said I'm committed to telling the truth
and I will be back on March 6 to finish
up
there's more to discuss so thank you
guys so much sorry I'm sorry you guys
have to stick around all day long all
right we'll have more of that exciting
news in a moment so Danny you're about
to say something it's going to say
something one is that there is something
about the need to be willing to take
risks mm-hmm in life okay that you hear
that so there you no risk no reward
that you live your life by that day no
that's risky
you took that plane to Mexico and I'm
not leading a country but I would say
that for anyone who if you're going to
start a business or if you're going to
grow a business if you're going to make
a leap of faith if you're if you're
going to try to make peace with an enemy
you have to take a risk and if you do
that you might be rewarded you also
might have a new cycle that doesn't feel
very good right but that in the long run
the long arc of history would will
benefit the risk figures yeah yeah and
as you remember Juan because they're a
little bit older than I am Gorbachev was
it Reykjavik with Reagan Reagan walked
out and said no deal and then he got
crushed by the media and then look what
happened they had several other meetings
and things ended up working out but I do
understand your point because
traditionally in diplomacy and you have
these summits all your underlings line
up all of these things that are going to
happen and then it's basically like a
big signing ceremony the problem with
that is Kim he's a dictator and he
doesn't have any underlings and he can
farm out any responsibility and he
refused to let them talk to the
Secretary of State which I think should
have been a tell-all trunk it's all Kim
they're the only individuals that can
make a warm beer really bugs me III
really buzzy but I don't understand why
you take the word of like this Saudi
Prince Ben Muhammad bin Sultan or
whatever
Salman I don't understand why you take
Vladimir Putin's word over our
intelligence people and now you take Kim
Jong on over our intelligence obvio with
me either
I think ultimately he's just trying to
find peace and he thinks that's a
strategy that's not a risk
that's that's an insult to us American
people I think it is a risk and I want
it what I want to hear from is with the
warmbier family we do know that the
chief negotiator agrees with Trump the
Israeli paratrooper Miki vegan Bergen
who hated it agrees with Trump that with
what Trump said but I would like to know
the family because Trump has a good
relationship with the want warm beers
right so let's put this wait see okay